As I said earlier in the course, the Piston function is essentially a two-way aim constraint
that keeps both bones pointing towards one another.
And we're going to set this up by using some nulls within the bone hierarchy.
Now if you haven't used nulls before, they are essentially like using a group in the
rig hierarchy when you're rigging in Maya.
They give you the extra level of control within the hierarchy, but they can't be selected
or transformed in the viewport.
So let's set that up for one of the Pistons in our leg to get some automatic movement
as the foot is moving.
The first thing I'm going to do is find our Piston function.
And let's see what variables it needs.
So it's looking for a start control and an end control.
And these are the controls that the bones are going to be pointing at.
And it's looking for a start bone and an end bone.
And these, as you probably guess, are the bones that we're going to have point.
The up control is something we're not going to worry about or need for now.
But the axis and the up vector axis are the same sort of idea that we had from the primary
and secondary axis of the IK3 bone.
So the axis is what's pointing down the bone, and the up vector axis is the up vector, the
up axis of our bone.
So the first thing we're going to do is actually create some nulls as the children of these
bones that we're pointing or that we're aiming.
So we're going to use these two bones here.
So the Piston 401, if I right click that, choose new null.
And then the Piston 402, again, right click this and choose new null.
Now you'll see that adds a null under the selected bone inside the hierarchy.
And again, this isn't something you can see or select in the viewport.
It's just something we can use to sort of affect the hierarchy or affect transforms of something
else.
And these are going to be our start and end controls.
So what I'm going to do is just right click, rename, and put underscore start on the end
of this one.
And underscore end, oops, on the end of this one.
And our end bone or end null, should I say, should go into the end control here.
You'll see the type starts off as none, but if you use this small arrow with whatever
you have selected, it will automatically update that type.
And if I select the opposite end to find our start, I'll plug that in there.
Now let's tell the node or the function what bones we want to use to aim towards one another.
So our start bone and our end bone, our start bone should match our start null.
So above the start null, we have the piston 0, sorry, piston 4, 0, 2.
We just plug that in there.
And then I'll use the magnifying glass to find our other null.
Oops, it's not working for some reason.
Try again.
Nope, okay.
Well, we'll select it from the viewport by finding the bone and then finding our null
here.
So this is our end bone that we want to use, the parent of the end control or the end null
that we're using.
So now we have our start and end control and our start and end bone.
And what's going to happen essentially is the start bone is going to point towards
the end null.
And the end bone is going to point towards the start null.
Now this is made possible because the nulls are children of the bones and they'll follow
them wherever they go.
If you were to try and make this without the nulls or controls in the hierarchy, it essentially
wouldn't function correctly.
Now what we need to do is check our axis and our up vector and fill in this information
here.
Now again, make sure that display axis on selection is checked on.
And when we select both of these here, we can see that X is pointing in the direction
that we want to be, you know, we want this bone to be aiming.
So it's pointing in the direction of the mesh and Z is going to be our up axis.
So these are actually set up correctly.
So if we were to connect the logic up here, we shouldn't see anything change in the viewport
yet until we start to move this foot control.
So as soon as we start to move that, you can see that our piston is actually compressing
and expanding, always pointing towards one another as this leg is moving and as the foot
is moving, causing that sort of realistic piston action there.
It's not incredibly obvious, but if I just disconnect this, you will be able to see just
how clear it is and reconnect it up.
And that's how you get a piston functioning with your control rig.
Now this has a lot of different pistons on it.
So you could go around and set this up for each of the pistons inside the character.
And every time that you move the leg or the foot or whatever it is, there's a parent of
these bones.
You're going to get that automatic movement of the piston looking like it's compressing
and expanding as the meshes around it are moving.